indeed L welcome to the studio
congratulations on your second victory
in a row how does it feel and what
happened today yeah it was a strange
game uh I mean I I feel like he lost
more than I than I won uh but uh yeah
that's how it goes sometimes I mean it
was a very interesting position like we
again got a pretty new position from
move six or seven so I thought that's
that's fine and um but that uh that was
so why we were spending so much time I
guess and but I play I mean I was
hesitating too much and I was changing
my plans and finally I think he got a
very good position out of the opening so
I decided to repeat moves at some point
and he got ambitious which uh it's very
understandable because his position I
think at that point was was pretty good
when he played B5
B and yeah with the idea to to put the
Knight on C4 and just keep playing
uh but yeah I thought my my position
should should still be fine I mean um um
um I think this H uh this when I play G3
now was important to be able to play H4
after I take on G6 so CD CD Knight B6
mhm so this what happened yes and you
took on6 yes I think he got ambitious
playing this F6 yes move this is
critical moment F6 maybe is not required
um but I think if I I mean if we trade
the Bishops probably it's around equal I
that was my my um estimation during the
game but I wasn't sure at all it's so um
not an e position to evaluate let's
instead of it yes he could take yeah
take Knight
G5 I don't know I felt that I was uh not
doing too badly here but U black is
obviously fine with the Knight on C4 but
after A6 yeah because the thing is that
he's King yeah and G5 was um I felt that
it was too risky mhm um because um after
takes uh and F takes D takes E5 there's
no
real um that's way to reason us to yeah
to compensate I always have this King G2
Rook H1 at some point and um yeah maybe
he can still uh have some compensation
but yeah I think the way he played after
Bishop C5 and then Knight D3 I think
this G6 was a very good move mhm and
after this is the moment you felt that
now you're better yeah well already
after uh uh I took the bond I felt that
I should be better and um yeah but here
I saw that it's I mean it's simply um
extremely good for me now it's just um
out material and huge attack exactly yes
and you managed to win this game um you
know now there are so many talks about
this candidate spot and suddenly your
rating is also became very important all
the standing so what do you think about
it have you discussed it with your
trainer like yeah it was quite
unexpected I must say I wasn't thinking
too much about this uh I mean I knew
that in theory I have some remote chance
but uh I wasn't especially uh thinking
about this I was just trying to play a
good tournament but somehow yeah things
are going well and it's always nice to
to be in with a chance so let's see yeah
tomorrow you are playing against Maxim I
think if I'm not mistaken yes so was wi
yeah yeah I have uh still two games and
yeah nice position in the tournament so
absolutely plus two I I feel that I
didn't play very well today but uh uh of
course a win is a win and uh I'll try to
to I mean to play two good games yeah
thank you so much L and all the best of
luck for in the last rounds and we are
going back to the studio for final words
I guess honest
I have a question for lanir if you don't
mind uh lanir how did it feel to play
against an opponent who was in time
trouble uh Le how was it for you to play
trouble tricky question from y yeah it's
uh um unusual a little bit but uh yeah
what I try to do is kind of forget that
he's in time trol because sometimes you
me this old trick from from the
childhood yeah like you try to play
moves with the idea to win on time and
you spoil your position so I was um I
was more happy about my position than
than about the time but it's always nice
yeah it's always nice when your opponent
is down to to one minute or so so I
should think about it from the other
side was something unusual for you today
yes I guess any questions yes no thank
you honia good luck uh um Good Luck for
you from Yer and all the commentators
absolutely uh fantastic and boy did the
tournament just explode or what that was
just